case keenum the Broncos quarterback
joins us now where are you right now
case of the Denver Broncos what number
did you get how about what number four I
think number seven was what if you asked
for number seven just as a joke I was
not I was not gonna bring that up I did
not bring that topic up when I came into
the building so for that's the number
we're going with yeah I think so
okay well what were the discussions like
when we saw you at the Super Bowl
I thought Arizona or Denver would be
great places for you
why Denver over what other option you
had that's because you called it man as
you told me you told me there during the
Super Bowl week that I should go to
Denver that's uh that the city would be
great yeah I really appreciate that
advice man it was it was perfect
okay but could I have convinced you to
go to Arizona you may have been you may
have insane Arizona because all the good
golf courses everybody ever since I've
been here man there's some great golf
here and there's a there's a lot of
great stuff here man we've the
organization is incredible man I'm in
the city of Denver a lot of outdoor
stuff that my wife and I love to do so I
mean it's a beautiful place man and I
mean I could dump 25 inches of snow in
Minnesota when we're leaving and we came
here in the sunshine and so it's always
a good sign oh you're gonna get snow out
there though case just letting you know
I did did Elway recruit you know I mean
it was it kind of all happened before
[Music]
you know before the free agency you know
there's no what do you call it the legal
tampering you know what happened during
that so I wasn't even talking anybody
did you know what the Super Bowl when I
talked to you where you were going
no no I definitely didn't okay
you know when you're what's it like
though when you you leave a team and
then you're going in there and you got
other quarterbacks like the awkwardness
of
when in there where you're you're the
new kid on the first day of school or is
it awkward well I did have those those
feelings the new the new kids first day
of school kind of nervousness my wife
Ethan I left I left the house and she
like wrote a little note you know like
little note like like your mom would you
know good luck it felt like it really
did but it felt good man it's a it's a
great place where we felt nothing but
but love just from the entire
organization from how many from there
like you guys are in the cooler room you
know the cafeteria staff of stairs to
coaches to Elway to you know it's been
great man it's it's a really great place
but you know the game here you've been
around long enough this is your fourth
team and then you understand the
business where Denver could be looking
at another quarterback how do you
process that that maybe they use that
high draft pick on a quarterback yeah
I've been in the situation before so you
know if it happens I'm prepared but you
know for me it's not not something I
think about or worry about too much I
know that upstairs are doing their best
job at you know putting the best team on
the field so whoever does come in is
gonna be somebody that they feel can
really help us and you know so I'm
excited about that
whether it's through competition it's
gonna make us all better for competing
you know amongst ourselves you know or
guys can come in and play or whatever it
is I'm excited for that will you watch
the dress odd I don't think so I'm on a
big office kick right now we go back
through the office on Netflix and we're
right in the middle of that best episode
that you've seen with the office oh man
it's hard to say I mean it's hard to go
against like original like office
Olympics we just saw the one where
Michael put his face in a concrete out
front
it was a good one
where he puts on the fat suit the fat
system there's a lot of a man there's a
lot of good ones did you see the
basketball episode oh yeah where they
play the warehouse oh yeah Kevin just
dominates
nobody knew that Kevin could you know
dominate and then Kevin's out there just
firing jumpers over everybody I there
way too many and I've been watching that
too and they're still like you still
laugh they're not outdated by any
stretch and you know Michael no Michaels
pretty brilliant there Michael Scott
yeah it's it's impressive just like I
think this isn't our third time through
it and we're still just giggling at
everything that's funny wait I guess
you've got to get another show to
binge-watch
don't you do any other shows yeah we're
uh I'm trying to think
we did we did Game of Thrones this past
year everybody was talking about it in
our quarterback room and they would kick
me out of the quarterback room because I
hadn't seen it and they would spend ten
minutes talking about Game of Thrones so
I finally caught up to where I could
talk with the guys about it and there
that's not coming out till like 2020 or
something
McLovin do you know then yeah it's
coming out I think in two years by the
way I advise case to get into a certain
show a reality show and I think he took
at our dad The Bachelor did you watch
The Bachelor well I may have been I may
have been on the couch looking in the
direction of the TV when some bachelor
episodes came on Wow my wife my wife
watched a little bit of that nice nice
adjustment there I like that you went to
you went to your second receiver there
I like that well done hey it's good to
catch up with you and have fun and I
know you're not afraid of a challenge so
good luck and we'll be we'll be watching
hey I appreciate it thank you guys for
having me on
that's Case Keenum the Broncos
quarterback for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you